- No, but speaking of, you
have your own new show.
You have your new podcast, right?
- I do, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Tell everybody what it's about.
(applause)
I mean, in the last
few years of my career,
I really realized how much
I loved inspiring people,
and I had this cool
platform where just being
out there was enough.
And so, after racing, I
thought the one thing that
I really want to keep
doing is doing that --
giving people inspiration,
making sure that
they understand that they can do anything,
and setting big goals and digging deeper
into themselves to grow and so,
this show came up as an
idea between a group of us
and I was like, "I think this is perfect."
So, I mean, it's so much fun.
Look, when you
- [Kelly] I want to be on it!
- get interviewed,
you don't learn crap,
because you just talk
about yourself.
- Exactly!
It's much harder to flip it.
- But when you do interview
people, you learn a ton!
Right, like, I'm sure you've
been meeting so many --
even more people than you already met.
- Yes, and actually,
it's like my first time,
like, in my life that I've
actually just shut up.
Like...
- [Danica] Oh, by the way...
- Which is working out! It
turns out I like listening!
- Yeah.
- I didn't know this about myself.
(applause)
- I sympathize, as I've said that one
of the hardest things for
me to do is to just shut up
and listen, and it's
almost like a discipline,
an exercise for me, in growth.
So, doing the show is really good,
and the shows are usually between, gosh,
an hour to an hour-and-a-half?
So, that's a lot of listening.
- Yeah, but,
(audience laughter)
at the same time, though, I do feel like
it takes a minute to really invest,
and you're wanting to do
something that's powerful
and inspiring -- it takes a minute,
that's not, like, a five-minute thing.
That's cool.
- It takes a while.
So, we're gonna be here a while?
(laughter)
- I'm gonna break down that
barrier in eight minutes!
- [Danica] Oh, no!
- I've been challenged!
- Yeah, well, that's the other thing,
is I'm very, very
vulnerable and very honest
and if somebody asks me a question,
I will answer it.
And, it's probably why so many
people love you, you know.
- I think that's why
(audience applause)
so many people look up to you.
What I do want to know is,
are you having fun, because...
Is retiring good?
- [Danica] Yeah, I mean,
like, I do feel like
I'm growing so much,
but when people ask me,
"You're retired -- how is it?"
And I'm like, "I mean, vacations...?
"Farmer's markets...?"
(audience applause)
- Yes.
- I mean, like, I can lean
into somethin' like that!
- [Kelly] I envy...
- So, no, it's not just that, but I mean,
I have a wine named 'Somnium,'
so I've been able to do
more stuff for that.
- [Kelly] Whaaat?
- Yeah, I do speaking engagements
and all kinds of stuff.
- You're very motivated.
- But a lot of vacations.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yup. Yup.
- Everybody's gettin'
a bottle of wine, guys!
- [Danica] Yes!
(audience cheering)
- I'm -- this is the first season!
This ain't Oprah, y'all!
- Oh, it's no, okay!
I'm sorry, Kelly, I overstepped!
(audience laughing)
I got excited.
- You gotta wait 'til the second season!
I gotta make sure people like this!
- I was gonna give you one,
and then she just said, "No."
- Well, me, mmm'kay....
- (laughing) I'm getting one,
you're going to watch me drink it.
(audience laughing) No, that's weird.
No, but, I was, like,
asking drivers this, like,
you're driving your whole life, right?
But, what about your driver's test?
'Cause, I find that most
- Oh, yeah...
- I find that most of
y'all actually did horribly
on your driver's test.
- Nah, I was good.
(audience laughing)
- You were good?
- Well, the teacher is
in the passenger's seat,
and they have an extra
brake on their side.
And I don't slow -- he was really nervous
and hovered over the brake a lot,
because I didn't slow down
because of brake lights,
I slowed down because of closing rates.
So, until the car actually came back to me
from a distance perspective,
I didn't slow down,
so I freaked him out all the time.
(audience laughing)
- You know what, though?
It worked out. (laughs)
- But, I was -- I think he's told stories
about me afterwards.
I think they were good, I don't know.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Who cares?!
- Yeah, I got my license.
- [Kelly] You have your own show!
- [Danica] (laughs) Duh!
- Did you do well on your
driving tests, you two?
- Uh, nahhhh...
- I almost failed mine.
- You know, no, I did pretty good.
You know, my worst driving
experience was the first time
I tried to drive listening
to a book on tape.
You know?
Because, I thought that
was a really good idea
and the person riding was, like,
"Aw, man, I been asleep for 15 minutes,"
and I was, like, "Me,
too!" (audience laughing)
You know what I mean?
(audience applause)
- Do you --
- Like, this is such
a bad idea to listening to a book on tape.
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding,
you're safe. You're safe!
Mindy, you do stunt work;
have you ever done any with, like, cars?
- I hire people to do precision driving,
but for the most part,
- [Kelly] I love that,
- I actually jump
out of the way.
- You just led with,
"I hire them (finger
snaps) to do it." (laughs)
(audience cheering and applause)
- Boss!
- Amazing!
(audience applause)
That's cool!